I want to make a little clarification
for the last three videos they've all
been of the form determine whether the
statement is always sometimes or never
true and explain why and then this was
the actual statement that they gave in
the last problem and to be frank I think
these problems are written they're not
completely well constructed because when
they say the statement when they say the
statement the assumption is is that this
whole thing this whole thing over here
is the statement that this whole thing
is a statement not just this first part
not just the 3x is greater than or equal
to X so if you assume that this whole
thing is the statement we saw in the
last video that this is never true I
mean 3x 3x is greater than or equal to X
only only if X is greater than or equal
to 0 we saw this in the last video it is
not true for all real numbers 3x is
greater than or equal to X is not true
not true for all real numbers this is
not true for all real numbers and the
reason why I say that this this was kind
of a strangely constructed question is
the I think the goal of the of the
problem writer is that they wanted us to
write sometimes which is what we did in
the last videos and but if you if you
say sometimes you're actually
interpreting this as the statement not
the whole thing you could say that 3x is
greater than or equal to X sometimes for
certain real numbers sometimes this is
true you can say this is true sometimes
but this whole thing 3x is greater than
equal to X for all real numbers is not
sometimes true and sometimes not true
this is never true you can never say
it's for all real numbers it's not like
this is true on Monday and then on
Tuesday this becomes not true in then on
Wednesday it becomes true this is never
true because this statement for all real
numbers just won't work you can't say
for all real numbers 3x is greater than
or equal to X I hope I'm not muddying up
the issue here but I want to make it
very clear because this statement is a
false statement this is a false
is a false statement so if you really
want to think about it if you view this
whole thing as a statement the statement
is never true it's not like it's true on
Monday and then all of a sudden not true
the next month after that or all of a
sudden it becomes true again no it's
it's never going to be true I don't care
how long you wait or how far in the past
you go this statement will never be true
that 3x is greater than or equal to X
for all real numbers x the problem
writer wanted us to circle sometimes
because as i already stated and I'm
maybe getting a little repetitive here
because I think they want us to think
about the statement as 3x is greater
than equal to X so my general opinion I
mean 3x is greater than equal X
sometimes for some for some real numbers
but not for all real numbers so you'd
say sometimes if this was the statement
and you would say never true if this
whole thing was a statement if this
whole thing was a statement hope I'm not
muddying up but it's always important
because I think sometimes some of the
hardest questions in algebra are to some
degree strangely constructed questions
where the answer writer was or the
question writer was trying to get you to
go in some direction and I actually
looked at what they wanted and that's
why i wrote said sometimes but if you
really think about it the answer is
never